bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 28
février
l'hiver va durer encore un mois mais à
partir du 3 mars c'est déjà le printemps
des poètes un peu de chaleur grâce aux
ardeurs le thème de cette 20e édition
c'est un labyrinthe aujourd'hui disparu
imaginé par charles perrault et créé par
andré le nôtre il devait instruire le
dauphin aversenq karine sanson bureau
des leviers comme un ouvrage et ils sont
7 et joue du jazz manouche arras et de
swing fait revivre django reinhardt
le groupe se produit ce week-end à
versailles en 1665 andré le nôtre le
jardinier du château de versailles qu'on
soit à larbi rentes qui servira plus
tard à l'éducation du dauphin un habit
rentes aujourd'hui disparu et c'est un
ouvrage qui le fait revivre et c'est
vous karine sanson qui en est l'auteur
bon choix
ansa là comment vous en est devenu déjà
vous intéressez un labyrinthe et bien
j'habite versailles depuis une dizaine
d'années et d'un jeu j'adore notre
promener dans le jardin et
le labyrinthe en fait n'existe plus mais
à l'actuel emplacement se trouve le
bosquet de la reine et comment comment
j'en suis venu à l'intéressé est attendu
à l'or s'est hissé en me baladant que
j'en ai entendu parler c'était un petit
peu mystérieux parce que en fait j'ai eu
quelques informations des indices de ci
de là et c'était un peu comme une énigme
à résoudre et avec toutes ces petites
informations mises bout-à-bout qui ont
fini par construire ce lieu alors dans
votre ouvrage il y a trente neuf
chapitres et il y avait trente neuf
fontaines
oui tout à fait trente neuf fontaines
qui illustrait chacune une fable d'esope
et donc j'ai illustré à chacune de ces
fables sens alors chaque chaque fontaine
a une histoire particulière
c'est très ses traits à nîmes a nié
aussi ses traits à huy
le principe des femmes c'est que souvent
et confrontent plusieurs animaux entre
eux mais les fontaines à l'époque du
labyrinthe à des tout une forme
particulière et moi j'ai cherché à à non
pas à coller à la reproduction de ces
fontaines mais plutôt à imaginer une
autre forme tout en faisant référence à
aux jardins de versailles virtuel quand
vous avez travaillé ce que vous avez
peut-être eu aussi accès à des archives
du château pour voir comment elle était
quand même à l'époque
alors oui j'ai eu accès à des fins pas
des archives mais il ya eu une
exposition phare en 2013 à la
bibliothèque centrale de versailles qui
est qui a mis à jour des éléments de ces
fontaines dont des sculptures qui était
à l'origine polychrome des bribes de
coquillages parce que tout ça se
constituent elles étaient constitutives
des fontaines il y avait aussi des
faïences c'était des fontaines
extrêmement fragile précieuse c'est
aussi pour cette raison que le disparu
alors vous disais tout à l'heure chaque
fable est accompagnée d'illustrations ce
sont les vôtres parce que c'est votre
métier d'être illustratrice et vous y
mettez beaucoup de couleurs aussi oui
oui alors ses couleurs je sais pas trop
quoi on dit je pense est votre
principale base une passe de couach et
puis des réaux de crayons de couleur
vous avez été accompagnées aussi
peut-être pour la réalisation pour que
ça ne se porte pas trop loin des femmes
nous avait été totalement libre pour la
création totalement libre en fête
quand
quand je suis quand j'ai rencontré
l'éditrice claire garnier
j'avais absolument terminer tout travail
d'illustration
après on a fait quelques ajustements
ensemble mais en fait elle m'a laissé
totalement libre c'était un projet
complètement personnel alors on parle de
femmes c'était pour le dauphin donc
enfants pour l'instruire est ce que vous
vous destinez un public d'enfants ou
c'est pour tout le monde pour ceux qui
voudraient se plonger dans cette
histoire là je pense que c'est
absolument pour tout le monde
et d'ailleurs les enfants très jeunes je
pense vont percevoir certaines choses
mais ils ne percevront qu'une infime
partie que les banques
ça permet de multiples interprétations
alors pour pousser un peu plus loin la
découverte du labyrinthe
il y a un site qui était mis en place
avec des vidéos et on les retrouve aux
illustrations bien sûr qu'ils sont mises
en vue en musique par william rigaud
c'est une autre manière aussi de
découvrir cette histoire fait louis
alors il se trouve que dans mon parcours
d'illustratrice la musique a une place
prépondérante g l'illustré beaucoup de
livres disques et pour moi ça a été une
évidence de mètres du son sur ces images
et c'est pourquoi j'ai fait appel à
william rigaud qui s'est prêtée
magnifiquement merci karine fonds sont
alors les fables du labyrinthe sont
publiés aux éditions il adore je vous en
parlais la semaine dernière dans le 7-8
culture à la compagnie tisseur de son
jeu proposé le week-end dernier une
journée dédiée aux enfants ateliers et
représentations rythmé la journée
nicolas landry s'est passé glisser parmi
les participants
samedi pour maxence et ses copains
c'était atelier musique
on a écrit une chanson pour un peu faire
réviser le spectacle de ce matin qui
parlait depuis recombiner par l'orque
1,8 nanteau tester les instruments
qu'ils avaient ramené j'ai chanté avec
le violoncelle et la guitare avec simon
bollinger ils ont pu essayer des
instruments sinon c'est le compositeur
de la compagnie thyssen de songe à
l'origine de la journée marmailles et
mahmoud destinés à la jeunesse
c'est un sujet qui nous parle beaucoup
puisque au sein de la compagnie nous
sommes tous artistes pédagogues ce
dernier tous professeurs des
enseignements artistiques donc que ce
soit de théâtre de musique une journée
conclue par une farce à celle d'angelo
du béal codir usante qui revient de
guerre des textes anti militariste des
xvième et xviième siècle présent ce
pays' du soldat parti guerroyer pour
revenir et of plein de butin on la
travaille sur un grand nombre
d'adaptations et traductions pour
vraiment avoir un texte déjà qu'ils
puissent être entendu qui puisse être
qu'on puisse dire est qu'on puisse jouer
et ce comme c'est un spectacle conte
destiné quand même un tout public est un
public jeunes à partir de 6 7 ans je me
suis que le texte soit suffisamment
compréhensibles pour tout le monde et
c'est un spectacle qui mêle aussi la
musique
donc il ya deux chansons qui encadrent
le spectacle un peu vraiment la manière
d'un spectacle de très tôt un spectacle
presque un spectacle de rue cet éveil
artistique était aussi la conclusion
d'une semaine de travail
la compagnie était en résidence à
l'espace de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux
non
le printemps ce n'est que dans un mois
mais les poètes ont décidé d'avancer la
date dès le 3 mars et le printemps des
poètes qui débute est avec nous le
directeur d itinéraire poétique
enfin bon sur nani et samira negrouche
une faux est alors de semaine placée
sous le signe des ardeurs c'est le thème
de cette nouvelle édition
jacques fournet que nous réserve ce 20e
printemps la bonne chose des surprises
comme d'habitude puisque nous on aime ça
sur le printemps des poètes comme sur le
reste de l'année dans notre
programmation
bah y aura tout ce qu'on retrouve aussi
habituellement dans nos programmations
c'est à dire des événements des
manifestations qui sont vraiment prévu
pour tous les publics autant des
ateliers des animations des animations
dans les médiathèques un beau repas à
villepreux et attrapes que des
événements mais on va dire
réservé aux adultes puisque sur le thème
de l'ardeur des acheteurs inévitablement
on est allé dans cette thématique là moi
ça me plaisait beaucoup d'aller dans cet
esprit là avec le bal des ardents le le
10 mars au prisme
cette année c'est plus les sentiments
l'année dernière c'était plus la
géographie on va dire qu'il connaîtra
peut-être ça le plus personnel les
sentiments les sentiments oui son pacte
le corps est très mise en avant voilà
c'est ce qu'on va dire voilà je pense
que à chaque fois qu'il ya un événement
on essaye de créer une surprise par
justement là le fait de découvrir des
choses de de voir que la poésie est très
vivante qu'elle est très active
quand on met des comédiens dans les bus
qu'on va encore le faire le 8 mars avec
ce qu'ils perdent jusqu'à ben voilà
c'est des embuscades poétique
c'est une occasion pour les gens d'être
surpris dans leur quotidien et c'est ce
qu'on veut faire aussi samira negrouche
justement l'ardeur le corps la poésie le
met bien en avant ça s'adapte bien il me
semble bien que la poésie met en relief
les choses et donc le corps et qu'elle
qu'elle s'intéresse cette question là
forcément est bon vous allez être la
chance d'avoir été là pour la géographie
l'année dernière sylvain didot le thème
d afrique est exactement et j'ai eu la
chance à l'occasion de faire une lecture
avec la violoniste marianne piketty
l'idée de construire un projet au long
cours donc nous nous sommes en résidence
à l'école de musique et de danse de
trappes avec marianne piketty et bruno
helstroffer qui s'est joint à l'aventuré
qui était hors piste et tout ça bien sûr
grâce aux itinéraires poétique et à la
belle excuse
fr l'association de commerçants de la
musique je suis ravie j'ai perdu 20
degrés mais je pense que le soleil va
très vite revenir justement cette
association on en verra le résultat le
11 mars absolument le 11 mars à 16
heures vous êtes absolument bienvenue
vous pouvez envoyer des mails à tous vos
amis nous vous attendons de pied ferme
avec tout cas nous y travaillons avec un
tel thème comme l'ardeur qu'est ce qu'on
attend du public ou qu'est-ce qu'on veut
tout faire transmettre canton et poète
écoutez je pense que l'ardeur c'est
jacques a bien fait d'y ajouter 1 est ce
parce que c'est celle ardeurs vous
disiez des émotions mais c'est aussi
l'art de vivre avant tout ce sont des
thèmes génériques grâce auquel parfois
on va en voir un peu plus loin mais je
pense qu on a essayé aussi de rester
dans cette multitude d ardeur qui est
qui est celle d'un artiste qui est tout
le temps sur le fil du rasoir qui comme
le funambule et qui sait pas à quel
moment ça va basculer mais il joue sa
vie mais il continue à rester sur ce
film je pense que s'il y avait déjà une
ardeur ce serait celle-là passionne
jacquin dernier saluera les gauche était
l'invité d'honneur cette année c'est
même nicole brossard oui elle aidera à
ba nichols et nicole c'est une c6 est
une très très grande dame de la poésie
de langue française elle est reconnue
comme ça à travers le monde puisque lll
voyage énormément et elle a sept places
lie depuis depuis des décennies et je
tenais absolument à avoir nicole qui est
une grande amie de samira d'ailleurs par
ailleurs mais qui est déjà venu à la
maison de la poésie que j'ai l'occasion
de de faire venir
et là le grand plaisir c'est qu'elle a
dit oui tout de suite dès que je lui ai
proposé de venir pour cette quinzaine
au québec c'est plus sec
non mais le plaisir de l'accueillir et
de lui proposer on a en a réalisé une
chose qui me semblait l'essentiel c'est
qu'on en a fait réédité aux éditions
mazette
sont installés à plaisir un livre dell
qui a 10 ans d'âge exactement et qui
s'appelle ardeurs voilà ce qui tombe ce
qui tombe bien les la thématique et ne
pouvait que convenir à nikon qui est une
grande amoureuse est une grande dame de
l'activité de l'activisme je dirais
féministe humains et et poétique et
littéraire et donc ça ne se pouvait que
lui convenir donc elle a tout à fait sa
place sur ce sur ce moment essences
locales attaque des trois mesures de 3
mars aller au marché municipal ne mord
pas voilà on y est allés à la rencontre
allant donc pas dans les buts voilà
aussi sur les marchés oui ça ça c'est
une tradition qu'on a mise en place et
quelques années là on est à bord pas ce
sera le lancement et on fera un coupé de
ruban politique c'est à dire qu'on a
fait imprimer sur un ruban un poème de
nicole et il sera coupée et ensuite on
espère débuter en petits morceaux pour
les gens qui veulent un petit morceau un
petit mot de nicole dessus merci à tous
les deux alors le printemps des poètes
ça va nous réchauffer un petit peu ça
débute le 3 mars et ça se termine le 18
mars avec un peu plus de douceur
puisqu'il s'agira d'une sieste poétique
voilà merci
si le printemps des poètes débute ce
week-end perception et illusions connaît
ces derniers jours l'exposition à la
commanderie des templiers prend fin ce
dimanche mais encore quelques rendez
vous à ne pas manquer un atelier à vivre
dès 6 ans dès 6 ans pardon le samedi et
dimanche c'est une performance de
richard dumas et olivier mellano faire
des palissades des oeuvres d'art le
chantier qui fait face à la gare de
versailles chantiers se parent depuis ce
matin street art
un projet mené par le collectif qui est
36 les fresques ont été commandés par la
société immobilière nexity avec le
soutien de versailles regarder
louis xiv règne sur la cité royale ou
plutôt la gare de versailles chantiers
derrière ces 98 panneaux un programme
immobilier 120 mètres de palissade
réalisé pendant un mois par deux street
artist waun efficace raconte l'histoire
de la ville de versailles du street art
inspiré de gravures anciennes et un
autorail light sammonds j'essaie de
mettront en valeur les plus belles
heures de son histoire
par exemple nous avons peint le roi bien
sûr on s'est approprié des scènes la
ville de versailles la vasière lavoisier
colbert quelques personnes célèbres et
mon art est basé sur les tradition
byzantine y parce que je suis drake
l'avs
j'aime l'histoire et la mythologie des
créations uniquement au pinceau débuté
au mois de janvier au sein même de la
ville
les deux artistes internationaux sont
les invités du collectif qu'est 36
donner de la vie aux chantiers d'y
apporter de la couleur de de faire un
lien avec la ville aussi est d'amener de
l'art dans les endroits justement de
chantier c'est un endroit très
fonctionnel à ces polluants personne ne
sait vraiment ce qui se passait nous
c'est d'apporter une communication une
nouvelle communication
la fresque sera visible face à la gare
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mai avant
d'être dissimulés dans versailles avec
clarinette violon et guitare le groupe
racine de swing et partage son amour du
jazz et du swing trois d'entre eux sont
avec nous au plateau on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes le temps de les écouter
[Musique]
tous
une
[Musique]
m
de plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
non
[Musique]
merci beaucoup alors je vais vous
laisser le temps de nous rejoindre
c'était patrick le jean lucien pagano
pascal votre os et trois des musiciens
de racing de swing un groupe versaillais
je vous en prie messieurs vous pouvez
venir nous rejoindre alors deux
guitaristes un clarinettiste moi je dis
là vous êtes 3 mais je crois que la
semaine des soldes vous êtes un peu plus
nombreux d'habitude vous êtes au moins 7
ça vient ça alors monsieur pagano
peut-être racing dessous l'histoire un
peu de ce groupe va l'histoire ça a
débuté en 2006 on a monté une
association et au sein de cette
association il ya des musiciens qui se
sont rencontrés il ya des affinités qui
sont créés et variés du coup on a monté
ce groupe racine de souilhe ddd
passionné surtout de fruits et de jazz
le jazz qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans ce
style là peut-être la simplicité de jeu
c'est à dire que c'est du ce qu'on
appelle le swing manouche bien sûr il ya
des très très grand musicien qu'on ne
connaît pas obligatoirement mais qui
sont qu'ils ont vraiment très très bon
dans un style de sites de django
reinhardt mais aussi on peut l'aborder
sous son côté simple musique
traditionnelle populaire est ce qui fait
que quand on joue on en a des enfants
qui a qui s'appelait on voit des enfants
qui sautent i qui commence à danser des
personnes d'un certain âge auront aussi
en mémoire les oeuvres de django et
d'autres musiciens et puis voilà et donc
c'est dans la bonne humeur et puis avec
le swing c c'est la magie du swing il s
est donné envie de danser j'imagine
voilà c'était un porte souvent
l'habitude d'attaquer mais là vous
autorisez le public
alors moi j'avais vu que l'adage de la
formation c'est faire plaisir et se
faire plaisir sur la vue se fait bien
plaisir
c'est ça qu'on aime fois par semaine
vous vous rassemblez pour jouer se
retrouveront au moins une fois par
semaine pour pour travailler un peu pour
répéter et puis après c'est les scellés
les sorties mettons à peu près de deux
par mois en moyenne peu près bonne
gouvernance à tous vous chercher
peut-être à faire découvrir d'autres
artistes c'est un peu plus oubliée non
non en fait on reste sur django mais
papa que les compositions de django en
fait on joue le répertoire que jouait
django reinhardt
donc ça passe par aussi des chansons
fajon gouren art de jouer jouer trenet
ou des gens comme ça donc ça passe par
là aussi mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
jouer
des oeuvres de kurt weill ou même de
musiciens classiques comme debussy par
exemple mais ça c'est ce que vous avez
aussi jango déjà donc c'est vrai que
dans l'esprit des titres peut-être très
connu mais il ya aussi beaucoup d'impro
j'ai cru comprendre que vous aimez
l'improvisation et c'est un style qui
s'y prêtent beaucoup j'imagine
en fait j'ai une amie qui se crée
[Musique]
les solistes en particulier on parte sur
sur sur des chemins de découverte
quelquefois on se répète un peu mais
l'idée c'est quand même de créer une
tension qui fait qu' on apprend en
échange on dynamise le rythme et puis on
organise les fins pour que justement il
ya quelque chose qui se passe aussi
vis-à-vis du public donc l'improvisation
c'est large improvisation s'élargir
alors vous êtes en concert samedi
si je me trompe pas le 3 mars qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir entendre qu est-ce qui
est au programme ce soir là bas toujours
pareil django django toujours et tous
avons essayé de faire un programme assez
varié il ya des choses un peu ric mais
comme tout à l'heure des balades
quelques valses on a dû mettre au
programme
les gens pourront danser c'est toujours
cette invitation à la danse quand même
ça à se faire plaisir
c'est ce qui vous motive à aller jouer
deux fois par mois sans traîner par
sadie j'imagine c'est un groupe amateur
peut-être sur voilà donc ça demande
beaucoup d'engagement
donc quand ça bouge c'est ce qui vous
motive ça fait plaisir oui l'art y aura
de gens vous samedi jimmy jump ailleurs
y'a pas que ça vous avez peut-être déjà
des petites billes vous jouez jamais des
compositions personnelles
non non non c'est jusqu'au suis arrivé
c'est vrai on n'a plus le goût de
du partage et puis de créer justement le
nom d'une ambiance qui fait qu'on leur
on partage aussi avec avec le public et
et avec de l'humour quand quand le
d'humour quand le doublé et en ciel qui
font aussi que donc c'est très très
ouvert on est amateur et avec la cette
liberté justement de cette ville et
c'est un concert qui s'adresse à tous
j'imagine tout le monde est bienvenu
surtout qu'il fait froid on va
laisserait générique français
merci c'est gratuit pour les enfants
et c'est gratuit pour les enfants
d'autant plus et qui peuvent mettre
l'ambiance pour danser merci à tous les
trois hommes alors pour en découvrir un
peu plus de ce qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure
rendez vous le samedi 3 mars prochain à
20h30 et ça se passe à versailles et on
ouvre maintenant une page de cinéma
[Musique]
cette semaine le coup de coeur cinéma
c'est celui de gaël pineau on part pour
le grenier à sel de trappes
cette semaine je vous conseille de venir
au grenier à sel pour découvrir qu
romane vous connaissez shaun le mouton
vous connaissez ou à la synchro mythe
vous connaissez chicken run voici leurs
ancêtres le studio britannique arman
propose des films drôles et originaux
avec de l'animation en pâte à modeler ça
c'est assez original dont image par
image
on va suivre les personnages qui vont
prendre vie sur le grand écran et la
d'encre oman le clan de doom nos trois
héros va affronter un clan qui est passé
à l'âge de qui lui est passé à l'âge de
bronze
ils vont s'affronter sur un terrain de
foot le
ce fils marc et c'est dur 1h29 nous
conseillons à partir de 6 ans mais il
plaira aussi aux adultes et c'est
pourquoi j'ai aussi lu une séance à 20 h
45 le vendredi 2 mars
vous retrouvez nos films des horaires
sur notre site internet cinéma grenier à
sel points comme je vous dis à bientôt
autre à l'ugc skywest une avant première
vous attend franck dubois ce que vous
viens vous présenter son film tout le
monde debout une projection en présence
d'alexandra lamy et elsa zylberstein et
jusque là moi je postais choqué ce qu'on
voit et moi chez la grand voile à
fleurance quoi sert célibataire vous
devez avoir un mille trucs à vous dire
entre entre parisien
ensuite je fasse et je lui dise c'est
bidon je suis pas handicapé c'est bon
draguer ta soeur handicapée physique
bonjour bonjour à je peux vous parler
woods a dit dont vous venez d'un non je
peux pas bouger
à manille les amours on vous propose de
revisiter 40 ans de féminisme avec
humour et pendant ce temps simone veil
met en scène douze femmes touchées par
la lutte contre l'avortement et la
procréation assistée extrait à
l'offensive des jets a chois à toi a
droit à du sexe
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce site une culture je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]